i have always said i can't protect
every job and every business
no chancellor could and even though i
have said it
the pain of knowing it only grows with
each
passing day
so i am committing myself to a single
priority
to create support and extend opportunity
to as many
people as i can because
even if this moment is more difficult
than any you have ever faced
even if it feels like there is no hope i
am telling you there
is and that the overwhelming might of
the british state will be placed
at your service we will not let talent
wither
nor waste we will help all who want it
find new opportunity and develop new
skills
through more apprenticeships more
training and a lifetime skills guarantee
our kickstart scheme will help hundreds
of thousands of young people into good
quality work
and we will help small businesses adapt
that's why we've delivered
government-backed loans tax deferrals
and tax cuts
in a free market economy it is the
entrepreneur
who is critical and we will make it
easier
for those with the ambition and appetite
to take risks
and be bold to do what they do best and
create
jobs and growth and
we will protect the public finances
over the medium term getting our
borrowing and debt
back under control
we have a sacred responsibility to
future generations
to leave the public finances strong
and through careful management of our
economy
this conservative government will always
balance the books if instead
we argue there is no limit on what we
can spend
that we can simply borrow our way out of
any hole
what is the point in us
i don't think now is the time for tax
rises we're in the middle of the deepest
recession
for 300 years according to the
government's own
figures we could be seeing 4 million
people unemployed
by the end of the year what the
chancellor's got to concentrate on
is keeping as many people in work as
possible getting those who are out of
work
back into work not on immediately right
now changing the tax system he's got to
be focused on that jobs crisis